(upbeat music)
- Come on,
(beeping) password.
If you wear a mask and you
have an iPhone with face ID,
you know this standoff very well.
Except that might change for you soon.
A new update to the iPhone iOS 14.5
is going to have a special
face ID unlock trick.
You just need one of these.
Yep, if you're wearing an Apple watch,
your iPhone can unlock
without seeing your full face.
How does it work?
If your watch is unlocked on your wrist,
and your iPhone is nearby,
but can't read your full face.
Your watch will buzz and face
ID will unlock, and you're in.
It's pretty awesome.
Here's what's happening behind the scenes.
Face ID tries to identify you as usual.
If he can't see your nose and mouth,
it looks for your unlocked
watched confirm it's you.
There's no actual scanning of your eyes
or what's still visible of your face.
See, even with my eyes
closed, it lets me in.
How well does it work?
Pretty darn well, other than the fact
that you need to have an Apple
watch, which starts at $200.
Talk about being masked in by Apple.
Let's do some speed tests.
Mask free face ID, 0.8 seconds,
face ID with a mask and
the watch feature enabled,
1.4 seconds,
and a fingerprint sensor on
the iPhone SE, 0.7 seconds.
Getting in with a six
digit passcode, a year.
Okay, fine, three seconds.
Worried about security and
someone getting into your phone,
if they have your watch?
Yeah, it can be done, but it's not likely.
Each time you put on your watch,
you turn on this whole auto
unlock feature on your iPhone
by entering your iPhone passcode.
If someone has that, they
won't need your watch anyway.
A bigger fear is someone
like mask man Kenny here,
grabbing your phone and unlocking it
just by being close to the
unlocked watch on your wrist.
What are you gonna do with my phone?
- Tweets, access to her Venmo, sweets.
- But Apple has some
protection against this.
You can tap here to quickly
lock the phone from your wrist.
In my tests, the iPhone and the watch
have to be within 10 feet of each other.
This is Beta software, so this
and other things may change.
Plus this Apple watch shortcut
is only good for unlocking your iPhone.
If you're wearing a mask
while trying to buy something
using Apple pay, the app store, or iTunes,
the phone will still
require your password.
So how do you get it?
Your iPhone needs to be running iOS 14.5,
and your Apple watch needs
to be running watchOS 7.4.
Plus you have to turn it on,
by going into settings,
face ID and passcode,
and turning on unlock with Apple watch.
Right now those operating
systems are in Beta,
and if you don't wanna wait
until the final release
this spring you can sign up
for Apple's Beta program now.
Anyone can do this, but
it's unfinished software.
So there can be bugs or battery drain.
So far so good for me,
but download at your own risk.
Either way, this software
update cannot come soon enough.
(upbeat music)